[Music]
great so tonight before we continue I
thought we'd take a minute to check up
check with Andy Richter see what stories
he's working on for next week Andy oh I
forgot
thanks Conan coming up next week we'll
look at the latest vacation trends
skydiving with the dolphins and is the
office funeral replacing the office
birthday party
and we'll look at a show we'll take a
sobering look at alcoholic
ventriloquist's Plus are the aliens
trying to tell us something
well awesome
oh it's Ari and find out why this man's
laugh is making it hard to keep forensic
work in the garbage and finally animal
catapults are they really making a
comeback
[Music]
perfect don't change a thing
thanks debut downand you gotta get a
running start from the parking lot
[Music]